it's been more than 20 years since Saved
by the Bell left the air and one of
those old friends at Bayside High get
back together for a series reboot look
lots of fans are hoping the answer that
is yes but we put the question to Kelly
Kapowski herself Tiffani Thiessen who's
gone from 90s it girl - cooking Queen
there's been so many reboots the what do
you think said by the Bell I don't know
if you'll be able to get all of us i
hack hey Kel our whole thing like doing
Jimmy Fallon making fun of it in a
really light fun you know a smart way
was the way we wanted to do it I'm
pregnant
next couple are they morris capacitance
one a premiered in 89 ET was on the set
as Bayside highs hottest couple almost
kissed Zack a total do your new Ferrari
oh you poor thing you're too upset to
talk right now
no it's kiss until you calm down he'll
Zack we got a little flashback et what
your earliest et I just want to show ya
who handles your fan mail my fan will
actually my mom an idea at least the
bangs were a little more calm down I
remember when I first started the show
it was a lot of Aqua Net
pretend honeymoon would be better now
Zack and Kelly fans listen up they will
reunite on dinner at Tiffany's
Lisa's cooking show now in second season
where as the most anticipated guest
comes on with this beautiful wife and
you'll get to see that you know sometime
of the seasons Tiffany is now 42 and a
mom to to during our sit-down at
Hollywood Ciara kitchens in the La
Cienega design quarter I asked her if
Habib Rea helps with the cooking I tend
to do the cooking and he does amazing
dishes he does the cleanup secrets to a
successful way to spin that yeah and you
like he does an amazing dish she does
look really does right it works well
you